it's mostly just like hooking up rather
than like dating yeah there's been very
few times where it's like there's been
opportunities to like go on an official
date right just so much sucks yeah I
love that for you what does a date mean
to you a meeting between two people to
see if they're compatible were you on
the apps at all I prefer to like talk to
people meet them in person more organic
get to know people yeah yeah I want to
switch gears a little bit and talk about
your relationship to dating and where
that's come from for you I don't know I
mean my parents are divorced so maybe
that's let's get into that do your
parents want you to date do they they're
like that ship of sale they know who I
am at this
point yeah nothing's going in there yeah
have you ever been on a date no